Casting is arguably the most important aspect
of a film.
It’s extremely pertinent to find the right
actors for each role, and in the age of social
media, everyone thinks they have what it takes
to be a casting director.
When the actual filmmakers go the other way
and pick a choice out of left field, they
can draw the ire of fans before even a frame
of footage is shown.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Most Controversial
Casting Decisions in Popular Movies.
The Dark Knight
Batman fans could not believe that Heath Ledger
was cast as the Joker, who was known primarily
for roles in 10 Things I Hate About You and
Brokeback Mountain.
Nobody could see how he could play one of
the most intimidating villains in comics,
but Christopher Nolan knew best.
Ledger’s performance was a genre-defining
moment, raising the bar for film antagonists
and earning the actor a posthumous Oscar.
Many fans now retroactively will say they
were always for the casting, but a look back
at the Internet archives say otherwise.
The odds were against Ledger, but he proved
all the doubters wrong.
Fantastic Four
Josh Trank’s reboot was doomed from the
start, as fans expressed supreme displeasure
with the director’s casting choices.
Some fans could not stand the idea of Michael
B. Jordan playing Johnny Storm, a traditionally
Caucasian character.
The controversy seemed silly and had some
ugly undertones, since race is not an important
element of getting the Human Torch right.
Once the film was released, any furor over
Jordan’s casting became an afterthought,
with many happy that the talented actor would
not have to appear in any sequels to the bomb.
Luckily, Jordan won fans over in Creed and
seems to have a franchise there.
Batman
Even before the days of the Internet, comic
book fans found ways to protest castings for
adaptations.
Many bemoaned the idea of Michael Keaton as
Batman, especially since he was known mostly
as a comedic actor and did not have the appearance
of a superhero.
But Keaton established himself as Bruce Wayne
for an entire generation of moviegoers, wowing
them with his portrayal of Gotham’s Dark
Knight.
The actor has said he’s proud of the work
he and director Tim Burton did, and it’s
easy to see why.
For some, there will be no topping Keaton,
which is a statement few would have believed
before 1989.
Casino Royale
When fans think of the cinematic James Bond,
a suave, dark-haired gentleman comes to mind.
So when the producers went with the blue-eyed
blonde Daniel Craig for reboot Casino Royale,
there was enormous outrage.
The website craigisnotbond.com was started
and some petitioned for Pierce Brosnan to
return.
Craig took it all in stride and redefined
the character, giving the franchise the shot
in the arm it needed.
After four films as 007, Craig is seen as
one of the better incarnations and all the
controversy surrounding his casting makes
little sense in retrospect.
It’ll be hard to replace him when he steps
down.
Aloha
A rom-com pairing Bradley Cooper with Emma
Stone seems like a charming winner, but Cameron
Crowe learned the hard way that wasn’t the
case.
There was much uproar over the director’s
decision to cast Stone as Allison Ng, a character
who is of Hawaiian and Chinese descent.
Though the defense was that Ng wasn’t supposed
to overtly resemble a person of her background,
many took issue with Stone’s involvement
and saw it as the latest example of Hollywood
whitewashing.
The film could not bounce back from the negative
publicity and succumbed to poor reviews, killing
its chances of being a box office hit.
The Hunger Games
Having Jennifer Lawrence star in your movie
seems like a no-brainer, but some Hunger Games
fans did not approve of the actress playing
Katniss Everdeen when she was first announced.
For starters, a primary complaint was that
Lawrence did not look like someone from an
impoverished place such as District 12.
In addition, the novel describes Katniss as
an olive-skinned, dark-haired tomboy – an
appearance Lawrence did not have.
But she changed her hair color for the role
and was a big reason why the films were massively
successful.
She won people over and became an action heroine
to look up to.
Spider-Man 3
Spider-Man fans couldn’t wait to see villain
Venom on the big screen in Spider-Man 3, but
the enthusiasm died quickly when they found
out who Sam Raimi cast.
Topher Grace of That ‘70s Show was hardly
the living embodiment of one of Spidey’s
greatest foes.
Grace did not have the physical frame of Eddie
Brock, a character known for being extremely
large and muscular.
Grace didn’t seem threatening, even when
he was wearing the suit, making the character’s
cinematic debut a major fail.
Fingers crossed that Marvel Studios gives
Venom another shot in the new reboot and do
the fan-favorite justice.
Interview With A Vampire
No actor was a better box office bet than
Tom Cruise in the 1990s, a main reason why
he was cast as Lestat in Interview With A
Vampire.
But the move upset many, including author
Anne Rice, who penned the source material.
There were questions concerning the short
actor’s ability to portray a character known
for being an imposing figure.
Cruise ended up turning in a great performance,
breaking type and playing a compelling villain.
Even Rice was swayed by the star’s commitment
to the role, learning that sometimes you should
wait to see the final product.
The Lone Ranger
Johnny Depp has become a global superstar
playing oddball characters like Jack Sparrow
and the Mad Hatter, but not every such role
is a proper fit for the actor.
In Disney’s reboot of The Lone Ranger, Depp
was cast as the Indian Tonto, which angered
many.
Depp is not a Native American actor, though
he says he is partially of Native descent.
In addition, the film’s depiction of Tonto
was criticized for relying heavily on stereotypes
instead of doing something interesting with
the Lone Ranger’s famous companion.
Few were impressed by what they saw, and any
franchise hopes were quickly dashed.
Star Trek
Replacing the incomparable William Shatner
as Captain James T. Kirk is a daunting task,
and when J.J. Abrams cast Chris Pine for the
role in his Star Trek reboot, few were happy
with the decision.
At the time, Pine had only appeared in a couple
of mediocre rom-coms and had not proven himself
as an action lead just yet.
Some fans wanted Paramount to go with Matt
Damon, but Pine quickly silenced the critics.
His charisma and charm perfectly capture the
spirit of Captain Kirk, and he helped reinvigorate
the classic sci-fi property.
Pine’s now on-board for at least a couple
more movies, cementing his place in Trek lore.
Those are our picks for the most controversial
casting decisions in films.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones get your blood boiling?
Sound off in the comments and be sure to subscribe
to our channel for more fun videos like this
one!